nearly 350 years ago
Isaac Newton came up with three laws of
motion that govern how everything moves
there are three pretty famous laws of
motion and they're not very complicated
but if I told them to you as clearly as
I can you would think that you're
understanding them but I think you
wouldn't and the reason is everyone has
ideas about physics and about how
objects move before they're ever taught
anything in a science classroom so
rather than tell you Newton's three laws
of motion I would like to tell you
Derrick's three incorrect laws of motion
which the ones I think you're actually
thinking so Derek's first incorrect law
of motion is an object with no
unbalanced forces acting on it will
naturally come to rest Derrick's second
incorrect law of motion is that an
unbalanced force causes an object to
move with a constant velocity we could
express this in an equation where the
unbalanced force F equals the mass M
times the velocity V so if you double
the force the velocity also doubles it's
just like being in a car as you press on
the accelerator you increase the force
on the car and therefore you move to a
new higher constant speed Derek's third
incorrect law of motion is that larger
objects apply larger forces to smaller
objects when a large truck slams into a
car on a highway the force of the truck
on the car is much greater than the
force of the car back on the truck or
you think about the earth and the moon
the force with which
the earth attracts the moon is greater
than the force with which the moon
attracts the earth but remember this is
an incorrect law of motion